faze rain has gone nuclear after months
of publicly criticizing his org he is
now beefed with Nick Merks leaked
internal company numbers and made
personal attacks towards the company's
newest signing I mean as always with
FaZe it's a show but the question
is will it ever end
[Music]
okay so it doesn't take a genius to
realize that over the last few years
FaZe Clan has been going through a bit
of an identity crisis a few weeks ago
Keith did a deep dive into what exactly
is going on in the business side of
things over at the FaZe Clan
headquarters and to sum things up after
less than a year of being publicly
traded phase stocks are in the toilet
their financial woes have set the scene
for what many are calling the phase
civil war between the OG members and the
newcomers where they bicker about what
went wrong who's owed what and what the
future of the org should be last time we
left off things inside the face camp
were getting messy OG members like rain
Banks and Tico were sounding off on
their dissatisfaction with the org ever
since they handed the keys over to the
suits to boil it down these members who
have been around for over a decade feel
like they've been left behind while the
org focuses on Ventures that don't honor
FaZe Clan's original DNA and during all
of this faze rain has by far been the
most outspoken with his bellyaching
since at least December of last year
he's been criticizing the so-called
Boomers taking over the org claiming he
feels disrespected as one of the people
who helped build the brand and even
called for the removal of specific
members you are part of the problem and
why faith has been dying and why
everything bad that has happened to
phases happen you've been compliant with
every single person that has tried to
hurt phase and a stealth phase out and
make money off phase and you've done it
for a salary in a position of phase that
you feel comfortable with you have a
full office in Toronto where you get to
hire whoever you want to have full
control of it and it boosted your ego
the one that you've had since 2012
you're reliving your ego and this entire
thing is a power chip and few to
maintain control in the company however
things hit a new level when rain called
out Nick Merks FaZe member since 2019
and one of the biggest streamers in the
world he claimed that Nick was only
brought on for damage control after the
whole tifu contract disaster and that he
gets paid a million dollars a year more
than any other phase member Nick Merks
eventually saw this post and addressed
it on stream I feel bad for the things
that he's been through and I feel that I
feel bad that him is some of the guy
guys
feel the way they do about the clan you
know
um and I'm not I don't intend or want to
get in between them or FaZe Clan and
what they're doing I mean should I have
a baby now chat so as far as this drama
goes and people people trying to
bring me into stuff I mean bro I don't
give a now Nick went on to say that
he wasn't going to get involved in this
so-called Civil War so that honestly
could have been the end of it however
Reign still had a lot more to say so
allow me to abbreviate essentially it
comes down to two things one rain
believes that the OG members aren't
given the money or respect that they
deserve and two new signings are done
for clout rather than honoring identity
which leads to phase becoming more and
more out of touch Reign also says that
even when they make new signings like
Nick Merks that on paper makes sense the
company does nothing to make the
collaboration mesh and this is honestly
his best point yes 100 FaZe is
up their new signings collaborations
whatever they want to call them to me
Nick Merk's association with FaZe is
nothing more than custom stream overlay
however this is not a unique issue I
would argue that most orgs fail to
properly integrate many of their content
creators I mean look at xqc he was a
member of Luminosity for years and I'm
sure many of you had no idea but for
phase what's the alternative they can't
go back to being the trick shot org
because no one gives a about those
anymore and they can't go back to being
departing org because that only led to
drugs and allegations so what's the
answer well apparently to rain his
answer is
okay let me just leak faze's most recent
Financial records 25k 224k 37k 94k 21k
48k 86k 33k and 1K and that is a month
now there's no way for us to verify
these numbers at this point but if they
are 100 accurate FaZe is losing money in
almost every single esport and while
some are a little bit concerning others
are downright unbelievable now you might
be wondering how the hell can rain leak
these documents surely there has to be
some sort of consequence well believe it
or not it gets worse while all of this
was going on FaZe Clan randomly tweeted
out this we want more women in FaZe Clan
to which rain immediately responded
leaking that the new member was going to
be Grace Van Dean the actress best known
from stranger things and that the org
only picked her up because of that the
announcement was made and things got
pretty ugly with a ton of OG phase
members criticizing the signing people
began to take sides which led to shots
being fired all across social media but
caught in the crossfire was great face
she had just joined FaZe Clan and was
probably looking forward to starting her
next chapter now she was getting
crucified by her new co-workers and the
charge was being led by none other than
rain as a result the two got into a very
heated dispute and well I'm sure by now
all of you have seen the clips since
practically everyone has reacted to them
online I just can't compete with that
man I can't she she roasted me it's over
Grace I'm sorry all I want to say is
your golden Valerie make stranger things
your entire personality even though
you're all on one episode you found out
about twitch through Tumblr not only
have you not hit a trick shot but you
don't even know what that is when you
were still playing with Barbies I made
my first million out of this industry
and on top of it you're excruciatingly
mid to I would never let touch me on my
drunkest night big man yo you don't even
know what a trick shot is like I thought
phase was all about like being cool you
know what I mean like I thought it was
like oh we're Gamers but we're like kind
of cool we do cool stuff we go like
party we drink at the clubs you know
what I mean why are you such a dork now
I can talk for days about my opinion on
a 27 year old that uses childish
comments in the name of trolling or if
it's ever appropriate to bring up
someone's past drug problem but honestly
at this point any opinion feels useless
because there's no end to it in sight I
mean they even met up in person to try
and hash things out and it only led to
things getting worse Grace stormed out
of the room and tears and said she would
leave phase if the video was released if
I call you mid you should be like who
cares what I say and if you bring up my
drug pass are you getting emotional yeah
well I'm just speaking the truth I don't
want you I don't like you okay that's
fine
I'm just being very logical I understand
how you feel but you brought things up
against me a terrible person really yeah
oh she's pulling the action up now
because I said that I'm pulling the
acting out how my terrible person
for what pulling the acting how is my
favorite person explain
I don't owe you an explanation actually
and I owe you an explanation
um Macho tell Vera that I'm not doing
this video and if they release anything
then I'm leaving please
obviously as you just saw the video was
posted and as of recording Grace has
removed FaZe from her bio and privated
her account Phase Clan itself has since
made a statement claiming that they
stand with Grace and Reign has already
responded to that himself so once again
I have no idea when this is
actually going to end I mean it all
feels like a psyop at this point
and if you're like me Aspen gold Ludwig
and so many others watching this unfold
you can't help but feel just confused
phase are no strangers to drama there
are also no strangers to signing people
with little attachment to gaming so I
can understand why OG members would be
mad at seeing it happen yet again but
compared to Snoop Dogg and the one
tweet they got from Kyler Murray
Grace seems like a pretty damn good
choice so why now and why Grace well
like nadeshot said on his podcast over
the years the OG phase members had given
peace and peace of the org away until
they finally lost control of it now they
are a fraction of their former relevancy
the dream team that they built is dying
and they aren't even getting paid for it
it has been a powder keg waiting to
explode and for obvious reasons Grace is
a very easy target what happens now who
the hell knows maybe Grace collects the
bag and ends her contract because of a
hostile work environment maybe FaZe
finally dies maybe the OG members get
control and we can finally see what
they've been cooking up to get back to
their former glory I don't know maybe
this was always just a way to get more
clicks and impressions
all I know is that I can't wait for it
to be over
so face to me was always just like after
the whole trick shot era was just like
this org that was just a laughing stock
like it was just complete cringe just at
least in my opinion the content all the
partying and like that and when
they signed their you know the Cs go
roster I was like no no I like these
guys on this team please I don't want I
don't want this to be the team that I
like you know semi-root for sometimes
um but now like that's all I think of
phase is is the Cs go team twist
Kerrigan Reign yeah and now it's just
like all these people are coming out of
the woodwork that I forgot existed